hi my name is Chris Gagne and I'm an
agile coach and today I'm going to talk
about the definition of reading the
definition of ready is a documented team
agreement it defines the conditions that
must be met for a product backlog item
to be considered ready to work on by the
team it's not a formal contract or
approval gate but rather a set of
guidelines that will help your team make
a good trade-off between minimizing
risks and getting started creating and
following the definition of ready
diligently can easily double the speed
in the agile team because the team can
stay focused on shipping working
software not chasing down requirements
for a real-world example think of the
recent loss or everything in its place
concept used by chefs and cooking shows
before they begin preparing the recipe
they carefully organize and measure the
various ingredients so they're
immediately at hand while cooking a
little careful preparation goes a long
way a good starting point is the
investor monic to which I like to add au
for you invest you stands for user
experience which includes research
wireframes mocks written content and
even visual design now mature scrum
teams with dedicated designers can
research design code tests and even ship
within a single two-week sprint if you
can't consider making user experience a
prerequisite for development work
beginning I means independent the
backlog item should be self-contained in
a way that there's no in Sprint
dependency on another backlog item n
means negotiable until the Sprint
formally starts the development team and
product owner can negotiate on the
nature and scope of the item on the
corollary once the Sprint starts the
product owner should not materially
change the acceptance criteria V means
valuable an item must deliver value to
your stakeholders if you can't clearly
articulate the value for the work you
probably shouldn't be doing it e means S
the bull the team must be able to
estimate the size of the backlog island
ideally using story points otherwise you
won't be able to effectively manage your
flow of work s means small ideally the
backlog out and should not take the team
more than half its brain to complete t
means testable the backlog item and
acceptance criteria shouldn't contain
enough information to make test
development possible for instance the
coffee should be between 120 and 130
degrees Fahrenheit it's much clearer
acceptance criteria then the coffee
should be hot create your definition of
ready as a team based on your unique
needs review it at each backlog
refinement and sprint planning meeting
you can update your definition of ready
at any time so long as your team agrees
to change
you